各位同学好啊，咱们上课今天上第三3课。
拖颜这。
第三十3课讲怎么克服拖延症啊。
首先说一下啊，咱们有3个月没有上课了。
三个月没有更新了啊，为啥呢？
绝不是因为拖延件是因为这三个月的时间呢，咱们在做编剧的训练营啊，做了一个编剧训练营，为期3个月。所以呢呃由于训练营的工作啊比我想象的要多。因为报名的同学呢比我们想象的这个这个这个多了一倍。然后嘞。
所以花了很多时间在给训练营的同学上课，包括批作业啊。
还有看他们的毕业作品，所以确实是。
经历了非常忙碌的3个月啊，然后咱们的公开课就暂停更新了一下，非常抱歉啊。
咱们今天开始续上，因为咱们特训营了啊，已经这个第一期已经结束了。
当然第二期又开始了啊第二期又开始了。但是这次咱们有所准备，对吧？调整了这个这个呃。
调整了一下我的工作计划。我今年上半年呢就。
把所有的精力放在上课上，把所有的精力放在给大家上公开课给赞，包括带大家的训练营。所以今年呢呃。
开始咱们再把这个。
课程的密度再提上来啊。
这是跟大家说一下呃，有很多同学问说那个特训营跟咱们公开课有什么区别啊？这里可以简单跟大家说一下这个训练营里面上的课呢呃其实是训练营是这样啊，为期三个月，一共30节课。
从课程内容上来说呢，主要的区别其实是。
更商业化。
更实操。
什么叫更商业化呢？就是说。
特训营啊，因为报特训营班的同学啊都是想成为职业编剧的。
然后职业编剧要进入这个行业。
最先需要掌握的其实就是商业天。
因为这个市场上啊能获得票房的，能获得。
这个这个这个大流量的。
作品大部分是商业的。
所以说，训练营更注重商业片，更注重一个片子的可看性。
这个呢可能更针对性更强一点。另外呢就是更实操。因为这些同学。
呃。
着急入行，着急上岗，所以呢会给他们一些更实操、更实际的方法。
也有一些更。
更实际的经验吧。但是有很多话呢其实是不太适合在。
公开课上说的啊，因为容易招黑容易招黑啊。
所以说可能就是更商业、更实操。但是我个人认为啊训练营其实最重要的是毕业作品。
毕业作品。
也就是说参加训练营的同学，我会要求他们每一个人写出一个完整剧本。
作为毕业作品，然后呢，我对我会对这个毕业作品。
进行详细的诊断。
给他指出问题和修改的方式，以及这个同学他本身在写作方面存在什么样的问题。
我认为呢这个才是最重要的。
为啥嘞？
因为在咱们这个行业啊，咱们。
多说几句啊，就是咱咱们这个行业里啊，目前啊。
编剧是有缺口的。
编距是有缺口的。
然后呢，但是。
投资方或者是甲方在选择编剧的时候。
他的第一第一准则是什么呢？其实第一准则是完成度。
这也是为什么新编剧很难得到机会。
因为老编剧已经通过自己之前的作品证明了他有操盘整个项目的能力，他能拿下，他能写完，他能有头有尾。
但是。
新编剧呢由于你没有代表作。
所以你怎么让别人信任你呢？
第一步卖出去就很。
但是我们说啊行业是有缺口的，他总要启用新编具。
总要很多项目。
相对小一些的项目会启用新编具，那用谁呢？用啥样的呢？
最好。
最好的方法以我的经验。
最好的方法就是一份完整剧本。
因为我平常工作里面啊。
花很多的时间。
去帮其他的投资公司选项目。
除了帮我自己选项目以外，我也帮其他公司做顾问选项目。
然后这些项目在安排编剧的时候。
每年都会有。
20%左右吧，百分之二三十。
的片子是会用到一个新编剧的。
那这个新编剧我们怎么选呢？
他没有代表作呀。
我们往往选那些。
写过完本的。
他有完整作品，虽然没拍。
或者他写过完整的小说。
至少证明人家有完成度。
那么我们特训营里面就要强迫每一个同学写出一个完整的毕业作品，作为你入行的敲门砖。
这才是我认为啊这才是。
训练营最重要的意义。但是很多同学搞反了是吧？很多同学呢去听课，但是毕业作品。
危写。
这个就是你的损失了，好吧。
也提醒一下，呃，由于咱们这个训练营第二期也已经开始招生了啊。
嗯，报训练营的同学，你们自己想清楚。
其实最核心的价值。
还是。
还是毕业作品，好吧。
你要做好思想准备。
我们第一期的训练营啊呃应该是。
这礼拜就结束了啊。
其实取得的成绩还是不错的。
呃，确实出现了几个好苗子啊，出现了几个同学，现在已经呃正式做编剧了。
有有。
有两个还在我身边啊，在我这儿。
嗯。
写的毕业作品吧，有几个也不错啊，我看到的几个也是不错的。
呃，在这里跟大家说一下啊，咱们的编剧课啊。
嗯。
到今年3月份的话，咱们编剧课上了就。
整整两年了是吧？整整两年了嗯。
可以说啊咱们的编剧课这个IP在。
行业内吧。
是有比较好的知名度以及美誉度的啊。所以跟咱们合作的机构呀，跟咱们合作的公司也越来越多。有很多这个同行单位呢。
来咱们这儿招募编剧，或者是寻求合作，或者是收购剧本。
然后鉴于这样的情况越来越多，咱们之前这种这种事儿来的时候啊，咱们一般是用社群啊，因为咱们有1个5万人的社群，5万人的一个学生社群。咱们之前呢一直是在里面发消息，哪哪照编剧啦，哪哪招剧本啦。
不是很方便啊呃这个呃。
今年啊咱们建了一个网站啊，叫编剧编剧课点CN啊，编剧课点CN。
嗯。
从今天开始，所有的。
呃，招聘编剧招聘、剧本剧本收购、剧本交易以及学习资讯什么的，全部都在这个网站上进行，这样的话变为留底，对吧？
特别是问问题，特别是答疑。以前答疑呢这个我们就在社群里答疑，以聊天的形式，对吧？同学问我一个问题，我就回答了，但是呢他留不下存不住。
过段时间呢又有同学或者其他班的同学又问同样的问题，我又要再回答一遍。
这下呢咱们这个网站上有答疑区啊，以后同学们有问题统一在那儿提问，我会在那里回答。这样的话留底，对吧？有同样问题的同学就直接看就行了啊。包括这个这个这个学习资料呀，一些剧本资料呀，也陆陆续续在往这个网站上搬啊，在这里感谢一下班委会啊，都是班委会啊，学委会同学。
在搞这个事情。
当然这个剧本交易啊、招聘啊这些事情也很重要，以后都放在这个编剧课点CN啊。
边。
编剧刻点CN好吧。
这个这个。
全都放在这上面。
那咱们就赶紧开始上今天课程的内容啊，这个关于这个拖延症。
关于如何避免克服拖延症啊，如何克服拖延症？为啥这个今天呃这个这个。
上今年第一课。
就就就就先讲拖延症这个问题呢，就是因为在咱们三个月的训练营里，我就发现呀。
写作技能、写作技巧，写作理念固然是一方面很重要的东西。
但是呢。
写作纪律。
往往是更欠缺的。
就有很多同学的写作习惯，写作纪律是很差。
表现最突出的就是拖延症。
这个问题其实在咱们之前的课堂上啊，我简单提过。
然后嘞。
我没想到这个问题目前还是这么严重啊，呃咱们得重视起来。今天呢就好好讲一下如何克服写作中的拖延症。
老规矩。
如何克服拖延症，咱们得先知道拖延症它是个啥。
拖延症它本质上是个啥，咱们才能对症下药，知己知彼，对吧？有针对性的去治这个事儿。那么说拖延症是个啥呢？
很多同学啊有一个观点认为拖延症不是懒。
对吧我也不懒了，我我只是拖延。
首先咱们明确一点啊。
婚言症就是懒。
灰延这就是标准意义的。
咱们得承认，就是懒了。
拖延症就是懒惰。
好吧，还有的同学认为说老师，你说的是那种懒惰型的拖延镜，可能有，但我可不一样我是哪种拖延呢？我是完美主义。
我是追求完美，我一出手必须必须得做到完美。我之所以现在没做呢，是因为我没有准备好。
比如说我没有看完您的课。
或者是我没有完全消化好，或者是我没有这个这个这个做好全部的调研。所以我现在就没有动手写。
等我全都准备好。
我一下手写一个完美的东西，岂不是更好？
很多同学有这样的观点，好吧。
这也是懒。
这也是拖延症，这绝对不是完美主义。完美主义是啥？完美主义是在行动中逐渐的完善自己。
逐逐渐的成长，逐渐的迭代，你原地不动，你算什么完美主义呢？
是不是你原地不动，啥也不干。
给自己找个理由，给自己脸上贴金，说这叫完美主义。
这是完全错误的。好吧，首先我们要。
给这个拖延者定个性，他就是懒。
不是完美主义，我们得清醒的。
认知这个事情。
不用不好意思好吧，不用不好意思，我说过啊。
搞创作啊，要解放天性的。
创作要解放天性，解放天性的啥意思啊？解放天性，大家不要误解啊，很多同学老觉得解放天性就是光着屁股满街跑。
可能是受一些新闻啊，或者是什么表演系的训练课影响，有个误解，老觉得你看他们那些演员。
他上表演课的时候需要解放天性，解放天性就是啥呢？就穿的很少，然后在地上爬在地上滚，男的女的往一块叠，往一块揉。
我们好像听说这个。
戏剧学院表演系会有这样的课程是吧？
这个理解非常的片面非常的片面啊。
解放天性绝不是指。
肉体上洗。
下胡来或者是不在意不在乎肉体，并不是这样啊，解放天性的本意是回归自然。
回归自然的状态。
这才是一个创作者，就回归自然啊，是一个。
优秀创作者必须要做到。
就是你回归到一个完全自然的状态。
然后很冷静，很客观的看待看待这些问题。我们说创作中啊，你要主观投入，也要客观抽离嘛。
大部分人啊主观投入能做到。
客观抽离就做不到了。
就是这个他没有解放天性啊。
所以说。
认识到自己的缺点。
冷静的认识到自己的缺点。
也是解放天性的一部分。
就好像这个懒。
拖眼镜，你承认他怕什么呢？
很客观的承认它的存在，很客观的承认它是一种现象就可以了。
咱们接着说探圆件啊。
那拖延症既然他不是懒，也不是完美主义，那咱们得给他一个定个性吧，给他个定义啊。
拖言症本质是啥呢？
拖员证本质就是对延迟享受。
不确定性。
没有信心。
就延迟享受啊。
或者叫要延迟满足啊。
延迟满。
比如说啊。
我们说。
再懒的人，再有拖延症的人。
他都有。
他都有些事儿他不拖延。
比如说。
咱早上起来还没下床。
先看会儿短视频。
是吧。
一看俩小时过去。
看的很过瘾。
然后呢，也没觉得很痛苦吧。
看的很开心，对吧？
你说这个事情。
他不费力气吗？
其实也费力奇啦。
对吧其实这个事情你做两个小时当中完全不休息，其实也挺累的。
你干这个事情的时候，你咋不拦？
你在两个小时内看了几百条短视频。
你咋不懒了呢？
就是因为这种事情啊。
他有及时反馈。
就是你每看一条啊，你都很快乐。
获得了某种。
某足。
所以他是一个及时反馈的一个事情。
人们啊。
普遍倾向于做及时反馈的事情。
也就是说，做这个事情随时随地有效果。
有正反馈，让你很开心，或者让你很满足。
他他是及时的。
那我们写剧本。
写剧本有没有正反馈，有没有满足啊？
其实。
咱们。
讲道理的说，写剧本带来的正满足和正反馈远远要比刷短视频大。
这个咱们得承认，你写了一个剧本。
这个剧本拍成了戏。
然后明星来演。
在电视上放。
数着你的名。
说他们说着你的词儿。
這个满足感。
咱们凭良心说，要比刷短视频带来的快乐要大很多。
不知道多少倍。
那你为什么？
放着这个快乐不做，而去刷短视频了呢。
就是因为这个快乐啊。
他是一个延迟享受。
延迟享受。
我们说一个电视剧的话，假设啊或者一个电影制作周期一年半起步吧。
就从你开始写到他班上。
到他跟观众见面，我们说一般的周期啊最短啊也要一年半，当然会出现有一年以内的情况，那种就属于比较。
比较简单的一些作品或者比较草率的一些作品啊，正常作品一年半起步。
你想呀你写的写几个月，然后人家做前期又做几个月，做筹备，做几个月，然后拍摄三四个月。
在做后期又是三四个月。
然后再送审等等号，对吧？所以一年基本上是出不来。
一年半起步。
所以这就是一种延迟享受。你做了这件事情之后啊，一年半他才会给你带来满足和快乐。
这就是标准的延迟享受。
人啊对延迟享受是抱有不确定性。
他就不如立刻马上享受。
就不如立刻马上小。
这就是拖延症的本质。
这就是拖延症的本质啊。
你更倾向于做那些。
立刻享受的时情。
我们小时候。
放暑假，放寒假都有暑假作业，寒假作业。
的问题吧。
的困扰吧。
是吧为啥呢？
就是这样，你玩啊。
玩儿。
给你带来的是。
咱们小时候主要是打游戏机啊，当时没有手机可以玩，当时主要是打游戏机，它带来的是立刻马上的享受。
就是人啊本质上对这个延迟享受，它有一个不确定性，它更倾向于选择立刻马上享受。
不光是人的问题啊，这是一个人的动物性的问题。
投子也是这样，对吧？朝三暮四那个实验咱们都知道。
投资啊。
他也是这种情况。
他选择及时正反馈。
所以说他是个本性。
他是个本性，你看这就是我们。
回归自然的去理解这个问题。首先咱们就是懒，咱们得承认。
有句话说，十鞭九托啊。
就10个编剧有9个是拖延者。
其实啊在我的工作中啊，我认为久拖的不止。
十边9.5托吧，是吧？到这个比例啊。
所以拖延症它是个共性的问题。我本人曾经也有过严重的拖延症。
我们大大方方承认。
拖延症它就是一个人的本性。
我们认识到这一点。
同学们认识到这一点，其实有个好处呀。
就说你看啊，既然人人都拖延。
那我如果把他克服了，我不就脱颖而出了吗？
握不就厉害。
所以说这是个好事啊，不要觉得哇老师啊原来人人都拖延啊，那好了，那我就躺平了是吧？你不是说它是动物性吗？它是人的本性吗？
本性那我为什么不遵崇呢？
这个在咱们之前的课程中，我也说过很多次人啊。
是由动物性和社会性两种本性支配的。
动物性的东西啊。
他往往塑造的是。
社会意义上不好的人。
懒的人从动物性的角度来讲，其实是优良基因。咱们可以这么去理解，从动物性的角度。
懒的基因是更好的基因，因为它可以保护你，好奇害死猫呀，对吧？它让你稳定，让你踏踏实实的。
但是呢社会意义上要求人。
要求人有自控力，要求人求上进。
这些事儿呢都是。
反人性的。
社会性要求的东西都是反人性的。
这也是为什么？
社会意义上社会意义层面，那些成功人士啊都是。
行动派。
都是非拖延症患者，都是自控力很强的人。
因为人的本性趋向于保守啊，这个咱们之前课堂还讲过。
那么咱们针对这个原理啊，咱们现在了解了拖延症的原理，它其实就是对延迟享受的一种不确定。
以及对及时反馈及时满足的一种本能的贪恋。
我们了解这个原理之后，我们就可以有针对性的解决这个问题。
结合我们在实践当中总结出来的经验，帮助大家解决拖延症有7个方法，好吧。
第一个。
奖励的角度。
从奖励的角度。
我们说。
拖延症的本质是对延迟享受的一个不确定性。
就是这个你对这个奖励啊不确定。
那么我们就有针对性了，从奖励的角度先来解决这个问题。
比如说。
从大奖励的角度，奖励的角度啊分一大一小。
从大奖励的角度。
你现在写完一个剧本。
然后呢，一年半以后或许会。
和观众见面，或许会给你带来很大的麻。
但你为什麼？
还是有点。
心里没底呢，是因为你觉得这个事儿啊他不确底。
不具体。
所以呢你在有条件的情况下，给自己设定一个具体角。
具体讲。
就是我写完这个剧本。
我自己奖励我自己个啥玩意儿。
把它具体出来。
把这个不确定的奖励啊替换掉。
比如说我自己啊。
我往往就是。
比就如说这个这个这个。
有个。
项目。
我如果犯拖延症了，我就跟自己说。
我做完之后，比如说。
奖励自己一辆车。
啊，你看就把它具体出。
当然这是大的奖励，你可以根据你的情况调整。
根据你的情况调整。
具体出来。
客服这个不确定性。
当然了，还可以用小奖励，小奖励啥意思呢？
就是。
创造即时政法。
创造机是什么？
我们说。
玩手机打游戏为什么能够？
让你沉浸其中不能自拔呢，是因为他给你及时正反馈呀。
写剧本为什么没有及时正反馈？写剧本为什么？
会犯拖延症呢？
是因为他没有及时生。
那我们就创造一个即时中。
我们举个极端点的例子啊。
假设你看我们的同学。
现在是新人啊，我们大陆同学现在是新人。
比如说你。
一般来说，新人啊一个字1块钱吧。
一个字1块钱左右，大家不要觉得一个字1块钱低啊，我刚入行的时候也是千字签元。
就是没写满1000个字，人家给我结1000块钱的账，也是千字签元，一个字1块钱。当然了，现在我一个字好几十是吧？你就说你吧，一个字1块钱。
假设你写剧本的时候，你每写一个字儿。
你的。
这个手机钱包就叮进来1块钱。
如果有这个及时正反馈，我告诉你，所有的编剧都不可能脱稿。
就绝对消灭拖延症了。
你每写一个字儿，那别就进账1块钱，每写一个字进账1块钱。我跟你说，这个事儿啊会比玩抖音打游戏还有意思。
你会更有你会非常有干劲。
因为他创造了一个叫及时正反馈这个东西，而且是钱。
他消灭一切。
那个那个那个。
刷短视频带来的快感。
对吧钱的快感是最大的。
所以说你看如果写剧本有及时性反馈，那编剧就不可能是。
拖炎症的仲裁去了。
我们说去网吧打游戏，我们年轻的时候都去网吧通宵，去网吧通宵打游戏，从来没有一个人犯拖眼镜。
从来没有一个人打开电脑，磨磨唧唧，哎呀，进游戏慢点进吧，我先干点，我还没准备好，我等会儿再进服务器吧，不可能的，每个人都在那迫不及待，而且还在那骂这什么网速啊，我怎么还没进去啊，对吧？
为什么？
就因为那个玩意儿它有及时正反馈啊。
所以说你看写作。
写剧本。
你要给自己创造一个。
及时正反馈。
比如说。
你每天写写完多少字之后。
奖励自己吃点好的，吃个冰淇淋，或者每天写完多少字之后，奖励自己干点啥，干点什么你开心的事。
给自己创造这个这叫小奖励。
大奖励把它具体出来。小奖励呢？
然后让他平繁起来。
这样的话你自己去创造一个正。
这就是。
解决拖延症，从原理的角度，第一个方。
第二个方法。
就我们犯拖延症的那些事儿啊，他往往是一个。
大的事儿除了没有及时正反馈以外啊，它往往是一个复杂工程。
简单工程啊。
很难反拖圆价。
比如说这儿有一块砖。
有点碍事儿，走路有点碍事儿，我让你把它搬到外面去。
就一块砖的事儿，很少有人有拖延镜，因为太简单了。
所以说犯拖延证呢，往往是这个任务啊，他有时候挺复杂。
比如说一个剧本。
特别是一个电视剧剧本。
几十万次。
这他妈啥时候是个头呢？对吧？几十万字，然后嘞。
比如说700多场戏。
这啥时候是个头呢？
这时候啊。
就要把庞大的任务拆解。
我们叫拆解任务。
做计划。
拆解任务做计划。
这也是克服拖延症的一个重要方法。你把庞大的任务啊一拆解，你就会发现每天啊。
不用你写多少场的，每天写不了多少字的。
这个这个事情啊。
也是克服拖延这样一个有效的方法。
咱们大部分同学啊。
有拖延症的同学啊，他是怎么他是怎么做事的呢？比如说啊咱们随便说。
假设这个剧本30万字。
30万字，然后呢，他人生当中一天最多一次写过15000字。
然后呢，他就給自己。
一个拖延症的西里安慰说，我最后20天再写。
20天1005000正好30万是吧？
但我告诉你，这种情况下。
基本上就完蛋了。
到了那天你也写不了。
肯定会出点啥事，为啥呢？因为这就是标准的团。
标准的船统。
正确的方法是从你接到任务的当天，就把这个任务拆解了。你就会发现每天的工作量并不大。
把它拆解了之后，你就会发现你整个任务可控可执行。
比如说每天只需要工作1小时。
其实啊关于写作，我是不提倡大家每天写作超过4小时的。
你如果是专业写作，我都不推荐你。
超过4小时，你如果是业余，我认为两个小时就足够了。你每天把两个小时刷短视频的时间换成写作。
日积月累，你就会发现你你可以完成一个非常庞大的计划。
就是用这种拆解的方法啊，就是用这种拆解的方法。
把这个庞大的任务。
变得可执行。你就会发现。
每天的工作啊其实并不多啊。
然后第三种方法。
就是从。
把那些给你及时反馈的那些干扰因素。
关闭干扰。
为啥呢？
因为你。
再给自己定目标。
再拆解这个计划。
太阳。
这个事儿啊，他也不如手机香啊。
是吧哈？
你再拆解，再有正反馈，实际上他还是没有刷短视频，躺在那里玩短视频更安逸，或者躺在那里打游戏更安逸，对吧？所以呢在工作期间把这个干扰关闭。
我们小时候干扰一般是游戏机啊或者电视啊，对吧？
或者是看小说啊什么的对吧？现在的干扰比较单一，就是手机就是手机，一切的干扰都来自于手机。
所以在工作期间把手机关掉，对吧？或者把手机调到工作模式。
这个是很重要的一个事情啊，把这个。
关闭。
游戏。
关闭短视频，关闭游戏啊。
同学们，我自己也有拖延症啊，我刚才说过啊，举我自己的例子。
这个这个这个我的拖延症其实曾经也挺严重的。
呃。
很大一部分原因来自于打网游啊，打网游。
我是怎么戒掉这个事儿的呢？我就是有一次我其实打了20年的网游，同学们打了20年的网游。
呃，当然当中断断续续啊也也玩不同的游戏。有一次我玩一个游戏，这个游戏出了一个叫游戏生涯总结。
就是他总结了我打了多长时间游戏，升了多少级，什么什么，反正做了一个那种回顾，自动生成了一个你的游戏生涯回顾。
我觉得这个东西吧。
设计出这个活动的这个产品经理啊，应该被开除。
因为他并没有给我带来很多的荣耀感，反而让我发现，我操我在这个游戏上怎么浪费了这么多的时间和金钱呀。
而且我当时算了算那个时间，如果用来写剧本。
能写三部戏。
就会发现，虽然我不是一个重度网瘾患者啊，我其实每天打游戏也就打个半个小时一个小时。
很克制，但是你就会发现日积月累啊。
还是严重的影响了你的工作。
浪费了很多时间，所以当时我就把游戏戒掉了。
这也是我说的，你只要拆分开啊。其实。
你可以做成一个很大的工程啊，游戏是个反面例子。当然主要是说的大家要关闭手机，关闭干扰啊，这是第三个方法。
第四个方法。
在。
客服。
会员证里面。
有一个非常著名的叫十分钟法则。
这个。
国内外都经常提啊1分钟法则。
客服拖延证就是你不想干对吧？什么事你不想干正事不想干，不想写的时候啊。
你说服自己。
先写10分钟。
十分钟你总有吧。
十分钟你总能坚持吧。
先写10分钟还不行吗？
这就是著名的10分钟法则。
什么能？。
不想干，不想写的时候，特别是早上起来，对吧？早上起来是扩延症的重灾区，磨磨唧唧，这个没干完，那个没干完，对吧？，一会儿又要又要说哎呀，我要不先洗衣服吧，哎呀，要不先收拾收拾这个吧，就磨磨唧唧就不开始干活。
先十分钟还不行。
先写10分钟。
這就是。
著名的1分钟法则，这个法则的原理是啥呢？其实就是让你进入状态。
我们很多时候啊在在这个。
面对由于长时间的拖延症啊，由于你长时间的拖延症困扰，所以你在面对任务的时候啊，实际上是带着恐慌的。
很多时候啊你是高估了这个任务的困难性。
你只要先写1分钟啊。
往往你就进入状态。
你会不知不觉发现10分钟很快就过去了，一个小时两个小时。
也过去了，你就工作起来。
所以说这就是十分钟法则，它的原理。
其实他就是。
告诉你，你高估了。
任务的困难性了。
你只要开始动手进入到里面也就没有那么困难了啊，这就是1分钟法则。
配合十分钟法则，我们再提出一个方法啊，配合十分钟法则叫我最爱的一场戏。
就是我们在写剧本的时候啊，在做一个项目的时候啊。
有时候。
下手。
虽然十分钟法则好用，但是呢下手有时候写不出来。
那我建议你，你先写你整个结构当中你最喜欢的一场戏，最喜欢的一段戏。
这个项目是你想出来的，这个故事是你构思出来的这些人物是你创造出来。
你即便还没有整体思路，还没有完全想好咋写，但是你必然有你最喜欢的那么几场戏。
对吧因为有些对抗，你是在创造人物的时候就已经想好了。
你是在构建环境的时候，就已经想好在这儿要发生一个什么事儿了。
先写那一场。
先写那一场呀。
能够帮助你。
快速的进入状态。
就是。
写你最爱的一戏。
第五方。
第六个方法。
我叫他。
为了谁？
啥意思啊？
就是。
拖延症严重的这些同学啊。
往往就是我说的那种内驱力比较差。
啥叫内驱力啊？
内驱力也叫自驱力。
就是。
你可以测试一下你是不是缺乏内驱力的人。
就是一个事情啊。
如果是别人拜托你。
这个事儿是帮别人的对别人好的事情。
你往往比较上心。
但是呢这个事情如果只是对你自己负责任。
做了之后对你好。
你反而拖拖拉拉。
最後。
往往不了了之了。
这种情况就是典型的缺乏内驱力或者缺乏自驱力。
那为什么别人的事儿往往比较上心呢？因为那是外驱理。
就这个事情啊，你如果没有做好，别人会很失望。
你受不了别人失望。
外驱力趋势你做的比较好。
但是如果一个事情你明明知道你如果咬咬牙做了。
对你自己的人生，对你自己的发展会有帮助，会有好处，会有提升。
你还不去做。
你看这就是典型的内驱力缺乏。
这也是一个场。
这也是很多同学。
有拖延症的原因。
是内曲利权。
内驱力缺乏。
非常影响一个人的成长。
同学们，我在生活中认识很多所谓的。
成功人士吧，对吧？所谓混的比较好的人，他们无一例外啊都是内驱力行人。
都是行动派，做事情都是很果断的。
那么你如果。
内曲力差。我们说你有拖延症的话，往往是内曲力差。内曲力差的话，其实。
外曲力啊。
会相对好一些。
也就是说这个事情如果是为了谁而做。
你可能更伤心。
在咱们的班级里呢。
在咱们的特别是在咱们的训练营里。
我跟他们强调的是。
所有人写剧本。
你可以不为了你自己写。
你为了我来写。
为了老师来写。
然后你如果写不好。
我会觉得很失望。
我会觉得很丢脸。
我会觉得我教的不好。
所以大家。
可以尝试为了我而行。
当然了，你生活当中如果你有个很爱的人，对吧？你爸妈或者你你的爱人你毛定他更更合适，对吧？我是说你如果没有人毛的话，你可以铆定我对吧？为了我写嘛？为了老师写老师在看着你好不好？为了我写对吧？为了我写。
然后呢，其实还有一个很好的方法啊。
在实践当中用的非常多的一个方法，就是找搭档。
就找个搭档。
其实找搭档也能解决为了谁的问题。
就是在咱们实践当中啊，在咱们实际这个剧本这个职业编剧的这个这个这个行业里边啊，有很多的双人双人组合，有很多很多的双人组合啊，其中有非常多的夫妻档。
也有这个兄弟档啊，姐妹档都有。
我曾经有两个学生啊。
有一个是非常严重的拖延症。
兼抑郁症。
几乎都要放弃职业生涯了。
他年轻的时候很很很年轻就得过大奖啊，是一个非常好的苗子，好很好的编剧苗子是个女孩子。但是由于严重的拖延症。
伴着伴随着抑郁症，他几乎要放弃职业生涯了。但是最后咋解决问题的呢？
就是找了一个好姐妹，两个人一块儿写。
然后现在呢就克服了这个问题。
又呃这个作品又又出的很快了，对吧？有一个戏还是给我写的，目前正在给我写。
这个这个就是他跟他的搭档啊，他跟他的搭档，所以找搭档啊在。
咱们这个行业里面啊是解决拖延症。
呃的一个方法。
为啥嘞？为啥这个方法好用呢？就是其实就是解决一个内外内趋力转外趋力的问题。
俩人互相监督是吧？抱团取暖，两个拖延者互相监督，你看你写多少，我看我写了多少。当然了，大部分时候是写同一个作品。
有时候呢也可以不写同一个作品，两个搭档也可以不写同一个作品，但依然可以互相交换意见，互相监督，互相督促。
互相帮着想办法。
明白吧？所以说这也是非常好用，非常实在的一招。
咱们的同学啊，由于咱们同学咱们有社群啊，咱们有很多同学在一个班级里，你们如果。
感觉自己拖延症很严重，感觉自己内驱力不足，我也推荐你们。
在同一个城市找一个搭档。
当然了，现在这个这个这个交互方式其实是不是同一个城市的？
不那么重要，对吧？
可以视频嘛，可以语音嘛。
所以说找搭档啊。
是实践当中总结出来的非常好用的一招。
7条。
就是我给大家总结的克服拖延症的方法，克服拖延症了。
当然了，这些啊都是。
这个这个这个。
从表层来讲啊，从方法论的角度来讲，克服你拖延症的一些。
一些。
计俩嘛。
或者一些招数吧。
本质上来说啊，我还是希望大家提高自己的写作水平，提高自己的想象力。
如果你把写作。
修炼成一种享受。
是吧就是你不需要延那个那个未来的那个延迟享受，对你激励。你写作本身写作这个过程，你本身就能找到快乐，找到享受，对吧？你文思泉涌，下笔如有神。
这个这个你如果能修炼到到这种程度，你好好学习咱们讲故事的方法，好好练习，对吧？能修炼到这种程度，用咱们的创作方法能够如鱼得水。
那么你创作本身你就会感觉写东西就像刷短视频一样有趣，就像打游戏，你安排这些角色在这个戏中的命运线，就像你打那个角色扮演游戏一样快乐。
你最终要是拿能达到那种境界，那这些方法你都不需要。
因为写作本身就给你带来了及时正。
就给你带来了快乐，带来了享受。你也不会认为写作是一种能让你痛苦的事儿。
明白这个意思吧？
那这节课就说这么多，因为拖延症啊确实困扰着我们几乎所有的创作者。
所以我希望大家尽早的克服成为一个好编剧，好吧。
下课。
嗯。